les quartiers de reconquête républicaine
un dispositif mis en place en 2010 8 à
l'initiative de gérard collomb alors
ministre de l'intérieur
objectif majeur lutter contre les
trafics en particulier de stupéfiants
mais aussi recréer le contact entre la
population et les forces de l'ordre et
les partenariats avec les élus locaux
en ile de france 14 sites ont été
désignés pour recevoir des effectifs et
des moyens supplémentaires
problème les renforts se font toujours
attendre
nous avons le contenant mais le contenu
nous nous sommes toujours en manque
dixit l'ancien préfet de police de 1500
agents et faut pas oublier non plus les
services judiciaires parce que quand
vous interpellé une personne c'est très
bien vous interpeller quand elle comme
un délit ensuite vous avez les
procédures à traiter et nous avons un
manque cruel mais vraiment terrible
d'officiers de police hier à paris pour
cela nous avons alerté les autorités et
comme promis de l'intérieur mais pour ça
il faut une volonté politique et un
dispositif qui ne convainc pas les
associations de prévention de la
délinquance réconquérir ça veut dire
qu'on est en conflit ou un truc vont on
apparaît conquérir normalement c'est
notre territoire la république a
toujours été dans les quartiers c'est lé
maire quelle que soit leur étiquette
politique droite ou gauche qui ont entre
guillemets pour moi n'ont pas respecté
la république
alors comment voulez-vous dire aux
jeunes de respecter les lois de la
république
si ces mêmes élus qui nous représente ne
respecte pas sur le terrain on a laissé
tellement tellement les choses baa pour
y revenir mais aussi la politique des
grands frères que sarkozy nous a mis en
place on a retiré la police de proximité
elle tout ça on a retiré des contrats
adultes-relais qu'avec qu'elle a été mis
en place à l'éducation nationale on a
retiré énormément de probes de contrat
et on a favorisé certaines associations
qui sont sur le terrain qui sont pour
l'utiliser avant tout et qui ne sont pas
vraiment dans la présence prévention
mais sont plus dans une idéologie dans
une victimisation des politiques
infructueuses d'autant que les chiffres
de la délinquance flambe en ile de
france
rien qu'à paris selon les statistiques
de la préfecture
les vols à la tire ont augmenté de près
de 32% en 2019